how many times do you have this
opportunity comparing Baga side-by-side
well I compare food side-by-side all
that's sure RIA and I both make videos
about food all different kinds we doin
travel around the world eating food
together so we're excited to compare
these foods do you have a favorite in an
outer Shake Shack I feel like I like
Shake Shack better I like them both a
lot in and out is so unique to Southern
California so inexpensive for the price
I think it's incredible it looks very
appetizing
you know you know like when you go to
some fast food restaurant when you open
a burger it doesn't look like while in
commercial you know it's just a clatter
yeah but they say it's very plump no
you're right and it always looks like
this yeah so great job Poppy's a very
thin box very crispy and it's kind of
nice I feel like every part of the
burger doesn't stand in the way of any
other part it's just everything is very
well figured out and it just makes sense
together it's not the best bar that you
had but it's always there and you assure
you you will be fine I got you it's
actually my first time seeing this
packaging cuz I usually eat Shake Shack
at the shake Shack's same okay you're
ready yeah I think Pat baits thicker it
doesn't look a little bit bigger yeah it
smells a little bit more like charred
meat
you smell like beef
hmmm I think I like the beef better
actually Oh
overall the Shake Shack taste is a lot
richer has more of like a mouth coating
richer mhm do it which I wouldn't
necessarily qualify is better I do still
think that the in-and-out
taste is very distinct and it has a
different place for me I have to be
honest with ya
I like Shake Shack far better even
though it's twice as expensive if
somebody presents me whole in-n-out
burger in half Shake Shack burger I
would probably choose half Shake Shack
burger
I almost wonder what it would taste like
if you took a Shake Shack patty and just
put it in and out construction otherwise
I don't know so for our price comparison
we're gonna be trying the two more
premium options from in and out and
Shake Shack or in and out that's the
animal style fries I like this style
french fries shake chef lines like way
be you know I don't like it personally
not a big fan of animal style let me say
I think it's overkill same I think in
and out is about simplicity and you just
eat the fries with ketchup I am very
hungry for sense and we're trying shake
Shack's cheese fries which I think stack
up nicely against internet's animal
fries mhm some reason I don't like this
it's a little too thick and it's a
reminds me of frozen fries yeah I
remember based on the shape alone I
didn't want to like these fries but they
are admittedly very good this single
Shake Shack fry I think tastes better on
its own even though the in and out is
like qualitatively worse I somehow like
it more hmm I don't know
I think on a single bike basis the Shake
Shack is more impressive it's crispier
fluffier on the inside something about
the shape syllabus EPS upsets me though
well that reason I like hanging out
french fries
yeah I feel like you kind of explained
it to me yeah this looked like Wang and
I didn't notice that until now and from
now on I feel like every time I see that
sky yeah like Wang so if I feel like I I
feel like I don't like a box of
caterpillars yeah now we are trying
milkshakes yeah I need some vanilla
it's very eggy do you think a piece in
that it stinks like when you make
vanilla ice cream you put you make
Claire my grades I think really I taste
egg it's a tasty milkshake I you know
I'm not a big milkshake person in
general to me it's it's great it's all
you ever want it's cold vanilla e sweet
it's thick now for the Shake Shack shake
color from you know what's more yellow
do you think that's that's come from hey
um this is a little white our Oh
interesting
much more vanilla yeah this one taste
yeah this one tastes a lot more like
vanilla mm-hmm
the in and out shake tastes more
custardy mm-hmm whereas this one tastes
ice creamy
yeah I agree with you neither are bad
though I like this better
okay when I first had that you know
shake I wasn't disappointed by any means
and I thought this is a perfectly fine
shake but then when he tasted the Shake
Shack one it was clear
better yeah I wanted to like you know
better but shakes up is my favorite of
all I'd have to agree that I think Shake
Shack does almost everything better but
when I'm in the mood for in-and-out I
hold it in a higher regard than I do
Shake Shack so audience members which
one do you prefer Shake Shack or in and
out come on girl I love getting the raw
onions in and out I like it I like raw
onion but I don't like me after eating
that